manifester contre une telle brutalité
est un droit et une nécessité c'est une
réaction éminemment américaine mais
mettre le feu à des villes et la
destruction gratuite ne l'est pas la
violence qui met en danger des vies ne
l'est pas et le policier blanc mis en
cause dans le décès de georges floyd a
été arrêté vendredi est inculpé pour
homicide involontaire et actes cruels et
dangereux ayant causé la mort une
séquence qui ravive les plaies raciale
des états unis
[Musique]
lundi notre nation a assisté à
l'assassinât d'un homme à la télévision
il est scandaleux qu'il ait fallu une
semaine et un tollé national pour enfin
entamer le processus de recherche de la
justice pour georges floyd nous devons
rester vigilants et assurer une enquête
complète et crédible pour garantir que
tous les responsables soient pleinement
traduits en justice
le ce meurtre par un policier est un
scandale qui frappe au coeur même de
notre société
mais nous devons garder à l'esprit que
ce seul meurtre n'est que la dernière
manifestation d'un système qui dévalue
si durement la vie des noirs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est déjà assez difficile d'approché de
l'anniversaire de la mort de mon fils et
maintenant entendre parler de ce jeune
homme seul a un goût de déjà vu
c'est comme le meurtre de mme office il
avait fondamentalement le même âge
qu'eric
c'est le dernier d'une longue série de
meurtres d'afro-américains non armée
commis par des policiers américains
les autorités américaines doivent
prendre des mesures sérieuses pour
mettre fin à ces meurtres et pour
s'assurer que justice soit faite
lorsqu'il se produise
[Musique]
et
il